jennifer lopez has a lot to think about
these days between acting projects
music her just launched documentary i
was finding my way and her engagement to
ben affleck i feel great thank you
but et's learned there's one thing she's
not thinking about her ex-fiance alex
rodriguez who seemingly moved on too
like really moved on
[Music]
yeah that's a-rod sharing a kiss with
model katherine paget in italy later
that night the two hit the dance floor
and there's more from this couple's
retreat on instagram catherine posting
pics from their weekend away the two
cuddle up and hang out with friends on a
boat i'm at a point in my life that i'm
actually doing all the things i love to
do but a source tells e.t j.lo isn't
paying any mind to her ex over a year
after their split and doesn't even think
twice about his love life our source
adds that a-rod's dating life doesn't
faze her and jayla wants everyone to be
happy she wishes him the best but it's
not something that bothers her or takes
up space in her mind whatsoever
understandable j-lo the triple threat is
busier than ever i want something real
j-lo just celebrated the debut of her
documentary half time it's half
half time i keep saying like it's so
funny we're talking about this today
like champions are made in the in the
third and fourth quarter that's when you
win so i feel like there's a lot of life
ahead of me so i'm very excited about it
i do think it's just halftime et's
source says jen is so proud of the movie
which chronicles her preparation for the
2020 super bowl halftime show i had to
really figure out who i was
and
believe in that and not believe anything
else ben featured in the doc as well how
full circle of a moment is this for you
though it's a beautiful moment a
beautiful moment as ben stands up for
his lady in the flick speaking to the
intense tabloid attention that
surrounded their og benifer era of the
early 2000s
i really believed a lot of what they
said which is i wasn't any good but i
wasn't a good singer i wasn't a good
actress i said to her once
doesn't this bother you
and she said i'm latina a woman
i expected this you just don't expect it
you expect to be treated fairly and with
their romance rekindled and a wedding on
the way et's source says this time
around jen and ben are so dedicated to
each other and their families
it was totally unexpected the two
announced their re-engagement in april
jan sharing the news with her fans in
this video which features a cameo from
ben
ben came in and he got down on one knee
and he said some things that i'll never
forget
and he pulled down a ring
and he said will you marry me
and it was
the most perfect moment getting so lucky
it's not often you get a
second chance at true love
we feel very lucky
[Music]
you